this is how Gable I am we're at this uh
gas station and it's like 3:30 in the
morning 4:00 in the morning we're gasing
up my car this dude comes out of the
darkness this guy's just like hey man um
listen I'm working at the carnival down
the street and I just need to ride back
to the fairgrounds and my dumbass while
I'm gassing goes oh yeah no problem and
my friend Mark goes no man we're cool
we're cool and the guy goes oh you sure
man I need a ride or whatever and my
friend Mark's like yeah sorry man I'm
sick I
nah whatever and the guy so we get in
the car and drive and then as we're
driving my buddy just keeps going tell
me when you see the carnival tell me
when you see the carnival and I'm
driving and I'm like there's no Carnival
and he's like he's just up in my [__]
like he's like staring at the side of my
head he's like tell me when you see the
carnival he's like he almost got us
[__] chopped up dude he was like that
guy was a murderer he just came out of
the darkness and I was like come on over
friend but that is my personality